[Musique]
ce casting de poids
ouais vous présentez vos graines de
stars oh là là là et vous dormez aux
mines
parce que
mc
bene
[Applaudissements]
démouler
enfin
[Musique]
m
pour m
oui
m
des chiens
[Musique]
je faisais
ce
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les siens
à ses côtés
[Musique]
benmoussa
mais
m
arrachée qui sait c'est ma femme mais où
à new york
ainsi l'appel du pont de zaba et
romantique très dense et romanesque mais
tu viens la nuit comme ça rôder autour
de l'académie française
non alors certainement pas tarder non
non non je ne rôde pas autour de
l'académie française et l'académie du
taureau qui rôdent autour de moi
tous les cas ce bouquin tout le monde a
dit chez d'avant quand même embauché
deux à 6-6 ici écoute c'est un mot
galvaudé qu'il faut pas employer trop
souvent si deux critiques l'ont utilisé
ce qui est le cas tant mieux ouais mais
moi je perds absolument pas les pieds 1
ça s'est passé comment alors cette
formule 1 c'est ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'on tue encore moss et enfin non
mais quand tu qu'on tue quand tu fais un
livre si personnel c'est grave aussi ce
doit être terrible d'être obligé de
raconter comme ça alors ce mot terrible
pour l'instant j'ai décidé de raconter
livre le publier ouais fait que je leur
raconte dans des interviews n'est pas
terrible a été le poke fuite
le lac lisons important c'était de
choisir de le faire penser à l'instant
où je l'écris et pourquoi j'écris c'est
en grande partie pour essayer
d'organiser leurs données sur le papier
ce qui m'était arrivé dans ma tête et
dit réfléchir à tirer des leçons partir
de l'instant je l'écris mois quand
j'écris c'est pour publier
tiens et puis après tu t'es pas obligé
de le raconter pas du pain du tout ce
qui est bien que la littérature remarque
c'est quoi qui t'arrive
ça sert à quoi celle avantage c'est ce
que fait on le disait un et clément est
une éponge qui absorbe tout tuer ensuite
tu t'en sers ou pas mais moi j'ai passé
franchement j'ai entendu un an et demi
après cet accident
de santé j'ai pensé franchement que tout
ce qui était passé dans ma tête tout ce
que j'avais vu et compris tout ce que
j'ai traversé mérité que j'y
réfléchissais que je le mette sur le
papier avec ma technique de romance et
sert en le construisant comme un récit
romanesque mais en faisant le le serment
est le pari d'être vrai ne pas raconter
des blagues
alors ça c'est marrant parce que mes
copains certains copains à quiberon
confiance bien que j'suis pas tchatcheur
bouddhisme statut l'algérie dans un
journal que j'ai marqué en titre je ne
suis pas un charlatan et oui mais ce qui
m'énerve est un peu ses mots et sa
charge que j'adore c'est un très bon
journaliste
et c'est là à m'expliquer qu'au fond ça
devait être mon talent de fabulateur le
romancier qu'il ya fabule qui avaient
cru voir des images qui avait pas eu
lieu
désolé ça use voilà qu'est ce que tu as
vu alors maintenant tenir des
expériences fouet donc quand j'ai vu en
gros les deux ou trois choses
importantes c'est d'abord on voit des
éparpillement de vie comme comme des
petits cailloux qui sont jetés comme ça
qui en apparence ne veulent rien dire
qui ensuite avec le recul quand j'y
réfléchis avaient tous un sens bien donc
j'ai eu des boucs ma vie et en
particulier ma jeunesse j'ai
l'impression que quand on est sur le
point de mourir qu'on croit qu'on va
mourir
on va vers sa jeunesse son regard son
enfance on va vers les poufs et
rejoignent quoi oui on va vers des
moments fondateurs et ensuite j'ai vu
j'ai eu cette vision avec laquelle
débute le livre que j'ai cru voir tous
les morts de ma vie aligné dans une
chambre qui me faisait un petit signe
comme ça revient bien
ce qui est effrayant
ça me faisait peur et en même temps il y
avait une attraction il ya une tentation
de les rejoindre
et puis l'autre chose que j'ai vue c'est
cette espèce de d'expérience dont je me
suis rendu compte après coup on
vérifiera que d'autres qu'elle est assez
fréquente chez les gens qui sont dans un
coma et qu'ils peuvent et qui croient
qu'ils vont basculer vers la mort d'un
côté un tunnel très
dur noirs vertigineux et affreux plein
d'hallucinations et de l'autre au
comptant une espèce de d'avancé dans la
lumière et dans comment te dis dans un
sentiment de bien-être qui selon moi
s'il y fait que quelque part dans ma
tête j'avais accepté le fait que je
pouvais mourir et l'ayant acceptée je
préfère que ça se passe bien
tu écris quant à quelle heure la nuit la
nuit quand je me balade presse sur le
court 2 avr
j'écris après le boulot quand je rentre
à la maison et qu'on n'ait pas une
sortie un film où les copains ou un
concert et donc j'écris à partir de 22h
à nos attentes dans une piaule
tranquillou n'y a pas de bruit parce que
dirait on
du matin ou sera-t-elle s'endormir après
quand je suis malade à six heures ça
fait ça comme une fois par semaine écrit
quand je suis en écriture deux ou trois
fois c'est la mala vida quand même c'est
dur pendant ces périodes là non oui
c'est ce qui arrive dans la journée oui
ce qui t'arrive dans la journée tout
semble tellement pas important par
rapport à ce que tu écris la nuit en
même temps ma figure toi sans jouer au à
l'homme
protais que j'arrive parce que j'en suis
à mon dixième livre a tout à fait les
partager ce que je fais dans la journée
dirigeants actuels en voyant des gens
malades entre des rendez-vous en
m'expliquant avec mes collaborateurs et
laisser de côté
et quand je rentre en chambre en
écriture vous rentrent en religion
bon il faut un moment d'accoutumance aux
gens dans le manuscrit nos gens lisent
tout ce que j'ai je ne commence pas à
une écriture sans avoir relu dit pajot
par non et une fois que je suis entré à
nouveau dans la musique ça va question
comme défaut parce qu'en fait avec des
qualités n'ont pas du tout été du tout
plutôt beau garçon tu as un job d'en
faire don quichotte d'en faire ce que tu
écris deluna qui marche bien t'as fait
quoi cette fille non oui c'est ça hein
ok ça comme défaut alors que j'étais pas
au ciné je voudrais que mes films sont
pas extraordinaires avec le recul que je
suis insatisfait de tout ce que je fais
que c'est un maniaque un impatient que
n'écoute pas assez enfin c'est un peu
mieux maintenant
la voix des autres que fois paul qui me
manque énormément de choses je suis
incapable de faire un calcul sérieux
avec un chiffre quelconque
j'ai aucune notion juridique je mal
chaussé les avocats le formidable
nouvelle fois faire face à tout ce qui
est technocratique
alors j'étais pas un défaut j'ai trouvé
ton des forêts plus loin je souhaite en
effet le dernier mariage désunir idée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
en tout point
tuv peau et toi
est-ce que vous construisez votre
travail à partir d'une étude sur l'
influence du comportement sur
l'environnement architectural ou
inversement sur l' influence de
l'environnement matériel sur le
comportement ça se passe c'est une
relation entre les bleues c'est à dire
c'est la relation de la matière
[Musique]
gaza
messi
[Musique]
tu vois comme ça
oh [__]
bon je vous laisse en jeu la maison
à
oh
moi j'ai mangé une heure trois fois
j'arrête
manger de murs croisés je fais
l'accélération et c'est toi qui quittent
voilà voilà
tu veux des accélérations
il a tu es mort
ces pratiques 1
à
chaque fois voir
ben spies
enfin ses pattes et que je la
ressuscité pour débat de la partie et
confort
c'est le mur
hu
on l'a enlacé
stephen owen
j'espérais
les enfants suivent et bien derrière
attendez
necas est grave
à vrai dire je ne vois pas ça tous les
jours alors je passe vite et
tiens on peut avoir des choix
des jetons de jetons formations ont su
suivre pas à pas les clés tu peux
demander d'écrire dans fait un temps fou
c'est gratuit on connaît du monde
allez les spécialistes
sur les motos elle fait très très fort
elle travaille ici
et quant à la 5 minute quand y'a
personne et monte sur la moto et à la
taille elle m'a battue elle m'a dépassé
j'ai voulu le rattraper
impossible d'en manger en ville enfin
s'il annonce arrive à sa mère se met en
ménage franchement a cependant aussitôt
placée sous très dangereux c'est très
dangereux
ouais
voilà
s'affirmant ce que tu fais c'est
clairement le cas ce virtuel
elle a les clés
genre tu l'a séduit
dell trousseau de clés tu es bon pour la
journée d'appel comme en mai
malade tu veux le bateau tu vois des
verts au maire où tu veux les
monégasques begin arias et de biguine
attendit raconte qu'est ce que je fais
je tire pour recharger je tire sur le
côté droit et l'acheteur là
pour la route
là je tire geforce 8
comment quel bonheur
tu es bien pas moi j'avais su que
c'était sa vie de papa la maman on tire
mais c'est pas la même manière mais
sérieux franchement ton pas que c'est
l'algérie s'est dit on va faire la
philosophie est forcément les gens
adorent mais bon je trouve que c'est
quand même exagéré les gosses ils
viennent là je veux dire ça alors bondé
très spontanément ça bon enfin aider les
vieilles dames à traverser la rue la
tête tu te mets là à l'arrière
et surtout combien de temps tu montes
avec nous vous avez envie
nominé minutes voir ici avec huit
minutes à observer la tête ça fait peur
non pas du tout
ce pays
un livre entier
[Musique]
m
l'explosive nouveau
jessica newman à mieux cerner les choses
tout public aux anneaux mais n'est-ce
qu'un défaut
[Musique]
où
on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la nasa
oh [__] mais pas sur les jours au plus
tard
le sac à vomi les eaux
mais ce n'est pas cadré
mais quand j'appuie sur les maisons
seront pas ça tous les jours
c est non alors ils ont vu ils ont
ouvert plusieurs centres comme ça il y
en a plein italie je crois y en a ici
mais bon quoi c'était virtuel
oui mais c'est dangereux c'est dangereux
si je veux pas me la faire vieille
france et tout me prendre la tête ça
médard heymans et attendent
jusqu'où on va aller je m'attends y
avoir des départs tous virtuel
maintenant tu viendras tu mettras une
pièce tu pourras t'en prie en l'air avec
une bonzesse c'est extrêmement dangereux
ont fait un cancer espérant qu'il
veuille ou non
pourquoi parce que gérant car la charge
et manger parce qu'il faut bouffer mais
je suis un moment ils 12h45 sougeal
bouffer dont j'ai rendez vous mais on
peut se retrouver presque le reste mais
je vais quitter hermine de
clermont-tonnerre jeune fiancée finition
génial c'est très bien j'avais pas le
seul vrai qu'elle avait un nom à
particule
ouais enfin si j'avais pas mais charrie
pas qu'elle était princesse voilà mais
on s'est bien lâché l'émission on a fait
sur france 2 c'est qu'elle était elle
été à l'école avec ses fans mincoy aweys
ont lancé copine très copines très
précieux s'il avait toujours du jour
devant double jeu qui s'était aperçu que
c'était une malade ou descendez d'une
enchère de constantine extraordinaire
texte entier fiers de l'être
yves constantine ça rapproche voilà bien
bien bien passer à la télé bien bien
bien sûr
quand il faut donner une occasion aussi
aux gens de parler à la télévision
comment toi hicham ces deux jeunes
marocains du maroc à agadir aga dire
voilà ce qu'il faut quand même envie de
jouer de la culture ce que les gens
disent les arabes les arabes mais tu
vois à lui n'est pas lui c'est ce qu'on
appelle un choc non encore c'est un
combat repassant nous on fait on fait de
la culture des gens les gens pour qu'ils
râlent avec l'algérie les gens quand les
arbitres
le maroc n'est pas vrai les aghlabites
en arabie saoudite
d'accord j'ai un peu de culture bon
exemple au maroc ou en algérie il ya
plein de communauté
mais parlons de toi tu es c'est un
sahraoui dire qu'il voie des airs
voilà tu as des berbères mena ma mère
par exemple elle était super mer du nord
sorti fort c'est il faut il faut bien
alors comme on a des jeunes par exemple
il ya les chars oui il ya un an le dire
il y aller
il ya tout ce mélange c'est ce qui fait
l'unité les fêtes ce pays comme en
france il ya des corses
il ya un les alsaciens elle est bon s'il
faut le savoir
enfin peu de culture pendant ce temps au
chap ok tu fasses lorsque or bajeux
le nombre de cas par lula qui
travaillent là bas se souvient qu elle
moi je me soigne pour toi c'est un
symbole c'est l'énergie d'un moment
j'aimerais jusqu'à maintenant c'est le 5
a réussi non barel mouko 17
il a la tutelle d'étude tenue tu te
tournes préjugés c'est pas grave c'est
vachement c'est vachement sinon
meilleure chance est connu il ya plein
mais qui a plein deuil qui réussissent
d'el-mouradia aziz est sérieux on parle
de moi parce que je suis à l'arrêt un
acteur parce qu'il la lumière c'est pas
vrai t'as plein de mecs qui réussisent
puis discuter mais toujours avec des
mecs un mec est le mec il est avocat
l'autre image et mariana qui travaille
dans la bonne humeur
bon il avait un mec pareil partout on
les connaît ils sont pas avoir dit son
stage se veut rigaudeau burgod
j'accompagnais ma bagnole matin face à
lui ça va être à bien faire là ça va je
le fais un petit
ça te fait quoi mais qui par 4,7 alors
quand une copie c'est l'ancien couple ma
fille ouais duval pour son plaqué un
poubelle ta plaque et moi comme ça
portait pas mal comme moi j'en sais rien
et en france est-ce que tu la machine
suffisamment de parler de cul couple
mais tu crois que l'amour c'est que le
cul c'est pas vrai je me rends fait mais
c'est parce que tu passes à 23 heures
une première fois qu'il est triste mais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé va rien
ballario exil s'est passé quelque chose
à te larguer pour un emploi à temps elle
est partie en vacances ont été largués
en l'état dit je te large part en
vacances
elle attend celle qui annonçait le coup
tu ne vas pas faire un petit pont là
pour ressortir avec lui remarque pour tu
sautes 1% déroule c'est un bon pour tous
les deux
c'est qu'elle est vraie histoire d'amour
commence comme ça
la salade à plaquer et puis souvent
vives orange et il sort avec toi ce soir
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi pas
ce que c'est c'est pourquoi simple c'est
ce soir parce qu'ils la trouveront
continue secteur
on avait pour les jo éclatez vous et
pourquoi tu veux bien que tu dis bonne
bourre mais cela vivre ciao ok je lai
pourquoi être cher fils pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi divulgués hier soir
julien bardy s'en faut qu'on soit
bientôt sur mon beau il fait la bise à
tout le monde et c'est sa vente est
reversée à l'opt est à tout à l'heure
ouais ben saleh moi je suis je bouffe
est là et peut-être que je passe souvent
on a quand même s'ils ont souvent les
enfants
ciao longue vie à vous attends je
cherchais mon pote il est où ils vont
larguer dit long
[Musique]
quoi ça
ravie et très aimé nous avoir permis de
s'assoir sont extrêmement forte
notamment pour tous les deux là j'ai vu
un peu hein
très beau ce petit travail
on va voir avec grand plaisir
champion
toujours pas connue
ferlito royalistes
sinon
le sable
at il dit
deux navires
voilà
non
je
c'est pas mignon
alors là
enfin les
j'organise une très belle plage de
retour dans les chiottes
cet homme s'il ya dans une des plus
belles choses que j'ai vu cet homme
élégant on punit donc dans les babines
les étoiles et effroyable on peut se
parler parce que sinon on entend rien à
mon cas chasse et trolleys annonce à
l'origine j'avais jamais alors j'ai mis
du temps à faire aux jeunes collégiens
pour discuter avec les noms avec les
gens comme ça non c'est pour parler dans
une boîte 7 3 on peut se parler du sud
voulaient entrer ou dehors il fait frais
comme maintenant mardi - si toi qu'est
un livre sur le savoir vite se retrouver
enfermé chinois et là c'est pas très bon
c'est pareil tous avoir un bouquin
bayane non monsieur très joli
ce
saku
puis 10
[Musique]
ghabbour en ce moment sur ciné cinéma
rex ordinaire avant la douche tout
étonnant c'est que moi désirant lustre
tout
il en a cédé face
c'est une tâche aisée
je barry lyndon ouais ouais tu imagines
bouge il est tout un
les costumes pour à bordeaux les
costumes genre genre granulats de
coppola web tous les ardeurs faisant
dedans on étonné partir
l'udinese n'a jamais
et les coûts comme les gros nuages voici
mes cinéma
or si le machisme et c'est le plus beau
pour nous qui jamais eu de match entre
le paraguay s'est fait du plus jeune âge
et ça s'appelle comment chat mène
tout ça alors le buteur avec sa fille le
mec ça j'ai dit
c'est pas bien mais
moi j'ai accru des copines
j'aime l'eau par là jeudi m puis je suis
à côté sur ce passé il se prend le en
direct des schémas
quand new look est apparu
youcam soldats capello quai général et
les métaux schéma
coriolan dramé nommant roi de youtube
mais sachez monsieur ries new look avec
un pistolet
cette méprise
à mes yeux
la commune
[Musique]
allons chercher
the one show ça va
[Musique]
dans la poule j adore mon bébé
et b
voilà
voilà c'est fini
doucement
quand ou bwin à tout voir
il ya tout voir l'empreinte ya 2 heures
toutes les deux heures dans une nuit 2h
l'époque
là je n'ai pas changé je l'entends
l'antipode il
je vais mettre en pyjama du coup je peux
dormir
oui sinon j'ai ponge et même des couches
qui est en plastique au pyjama tout
matin puis s'en va et vient des couches
ça dépend des fois je le change on est
une preuve
et puis des fois non des fois il faut il
repart avec celle qui a suivi le ciel
est mouillé ou pas il vient tous les
combien tu variable quand il a le temps
tu peux quand comme moi je peux pas
forcément le temps lontan qui vient au
ca fait par deux en deux ans et demi mon
bébé
le toubib boîte ou y en a un autre qui
va se mettre à chauffer à crête
des fois je devais bo cd c'est pas
forcément du biberon des fois c'est du
pur et jambon ou alors des fois c'est
les petits pots salés pour l'âge qu'il a
dans sa tête ils ont quel âge sauvegarde
des envies et élevée aux îles entre 20
et 50 je crois que le plus jeune 22 et
non plus vieux 56 58
mais bon ça mais voilà si je le bats
aussi je suis un petit peu il se rendort
mais là je vais mettre sur la table m un
pyjama un bébé jama donc ça va ils font
des grandes tailles jouer parce qu'il y
en a quand même des fois qu'ils font
avec 90 et c'est vrai qu'ils sont faits
sur mesure ou qu'on h f
non les faits sur mesure on allant
mesure on allait entière qu'on leur
envoie un petit fascicule avec le tour
des faits ce sont des cuisses tour de
hanches trop des épaules enfin toutes
les mesures sont mesure s'il faut une
aisance pour pour la couche il faut tout
prévoir
année
ok
allez
voyez des couches en fait sur mesure
aussi non les couches nous achète tout
fait un magasin de bastille incontinence
autres mails sont pas il faudrait qu'un
regard fabricants et l'idée d'en faire
des couches bébé mais à but
wade qui l'a peinte en plus il ya un
marché pour brotherhood si sûr c'est
vrai que bon excellente comme couche
normal hein ce qu'ils veulent quand même
moi j'ai centaines de bébés
ah ouais quand même autour de moi oui
moi je les connais pas tous
je venais par courrier je le connais par
lettre par téléphone ou autre mais c'est
tout ce qu'il y en a qui sont mariés qui
ont une unique qui fonce avec leurs
femmes
voilà je pensais avec leur talent des
gens qui connaissent qui leur sont
proches ouais vous dirait que tu vois
jamais quoi non il n'ya que je vois
jamais je vais sur l'essence comme
client il m'a quand même tu vois je sais
pas je peux pas vraiment d'un
championnat
je ne sais rien tu sais pas parce que
bon je peux rester je poste un mois deux
mois sans voir personne
parce que bon sa disponibilité des gens
c'est c'est le temps qui sépare et
appelle des voyages votre iphone puis
voilà j'ai du temps là binôme j'ai du
temps pour me garder pouvaient non puis
bon des fois c'est l'après midi ce matin
c'est la nuit sans fonction ce que bon
ils ont ils ont un métier ils ont une
vision ils ont des responsabilités dont
il a besoin de choses comme ça donc en
fonction de ce hub faut faire mais quand
tu les contenus des changes comme ça à
contrôler quand tu es l'enjeu n'est
jamais un moment où ça devient sexuelle
il ya une érection mai mais un bébé de
trois mois à une érection qu'il ya trois
mois la direction
bon c'est normal qu'ils direction parce
que parce que c'est un plaisir c'est
normal le bonheur ça traduit par un
plaisir un plaisir c'est une élection
c'est logique mais bon bah là il n'a pas
lu la part de maxime sa rivale moi je
suis ne nous tue pas moi je suis là pour
a
je suis avec les deux pôles en bus pour
pour cette espèce de régression qu'ils
ont et leur faire vivre et puis bon ça
me plaît bien timbrée mars en fait une
place c'est amusant c je suis passé
search pour bébé à de likouala septembre
ces gentilles et c'est pisser c'était
tout bleu taureau c'est quoi je l'aimais
vraiment nouvelles chambres d'enfants
ouais bbb toi comment tu as eu des buts
non j'en ai pas donc c'était pour ça que
je m'accrochais à eux parce que bon
doigt une fibre maternelle qui est là
qui l'attend est qui et qui me permet
quelque part de l'exploiter de de
s'épanouir c'est tout donc c'est ça
maintenant peut-être bon peut-être que
nous fait même aller chercher midi à
quatorze heures non ce n'était pas le
jour où j'en aurai bon peut-être que je
serais tu prêt plus peut-être que je
ferais différemment mais pour l'instant
on sait comment elle a été amenée à
t'occuper de haut
c'est un calcul c'est un truc tout bête
un soir je faisais du minitel comme ça
parce que je connais le minitel parce
que parce que des fois c'est pratique
c'est un moyen intéressant des fois de
rencontrer des gens de voir des choses
différentes
et puis je tombais sur v à quelqu'un qui
m'a tu m'a contacté qui m'a dit qu'il
était bébé
bon je vais attendu parler parce que
j'avais vu l'émission à dechavanne bon
mais je connaissais pas j'ai pas mangé
du boeuf c'est pas d'opinion je connais
pas je suis tant que j'ai pas vu donc je
connais pas je peux pas dire c'est bien
c'est pas bien vous faut être débile ou
alors de ce fait on a discuté au
téléphone d'eau trois fois ci vous
téléphone je crois pas d'ailleurs c'est
lui notre enfance et au téléphone puis
après qu'est ce qui s'est passé ayé venu
chez moi avec son petit sac avec ses ses
pyjamas bar doute ces biberons ces
couches et puisse habiller lui-même il
s'est fait son biberon il s'est tout
occupé tout seul et puis j'avais je me
suis dit tiens pouvoir faut je ne savais
pas comment faire je n'osais pas le
prendre je faisais pas je ne vais pas
donner le biberon c'est un petit peu je
pensais pas trop c'est un petit peu
bizarre
et puis la fois d'après il est venu je
dois être biberons depuis vingt ans
après il est venu j'aime sa couche bien
joué il a dormi là il a passé la nuit
chez moi donc jamais canapé à l'époque
dans le canapé
et puis de fil en aiguille comme ça
karine est installé un petit peu oui
parce que bon je vais rire cette chambre
basse est que j'ai fait une association
et puis j'ai des associations je m'en
suis j'ai continué comme ça on est une
association way qui est à lyon et qui
puis bon lorsqu'il faut que tu entres
les barboteuse les pyjamas leur fabrique
on a on a dépensé combien de gens qui
sont des adultes m'adresse aussi sont
une centaine donc ça tout ça donc on a
un peu de contacts aussi à l'extérieur
on a peu de contacts la suisse la
belgique c'est maintenant de ses acquis
et les endroits où c'est en allemagne
angleterre c'est très répandu c'est très
courant aux états unis y en a des
millions j'avais carrément l'opulence et
puis bon la balaie les nurses passé
quelque chose de comment je veux dire de
normal c'est pas autant ils sont très
très très pure est bon très très coincé
les américains être ce soir failli
toucher au tout ce qui est sexuel est
très très bas nîmes autant lenner c'est
quelque chose qui est un ami du naturel
mais toi quand tu comptes tu fais je
suis pas content avec un homme t'as pas
le réflexe de t'occuper de lui comme ça
ou pas dans ma vie dans la vie sexuelle
sexuelles non non je fais l'amour
normalement un jeu non j'ai pas papa
tendance est en fait un pas vers une
formation professionnelle n'étaient pas
cotées mattern maternelle avec le bain
avec l'homme qui avec le bébé moi c'est
bien deux choses différentes et un bébé
il ya un homme c'est bien s'alimenter
mais qu'un homme bonjour relations que
cette mère qui s'est passé ici
bon attention l'association mon général
c'est un peu je veux dire un peu compris
dans les prestations qu'on va donc on
leur dit vont aussi bon ce qui est assez
vaste et les fournitures et les couches
et le lait il ya leurs biberons les
petits pots les choses que nous parler
des petits pots de nos lapins
la cei ins et du pot oui un petit pot de
chambre
ah oui un petit peu de gens de chez soi
ou plus je l'aï directement je trouvais
ça va remplacer mignon et voilà mais
voilà il faut changer là tu mets quoi tu
me tues mais pas de tomber une crainte
âge oblige attaque mais je suis mais du
talent je mets de la crème jeu mes
produits je vois un coup de pub produits
poupine à un paupinat mais voilà que
plus au final on saura pouvait venir
voir c'est bon ça marche bon quelques
plastiques break le plastique pour
éviter les fuites
la science
en généralisant par leur entourage leur
femme ghana women allons y en a qui dit
kiffa qui laisse qc des chiens continent
yann acl haïti le vivant secret total
ouais puis bon mois la mission demande
pas trop ça me regarde pas comment ils
vivent servir
moi je suis là pour leur bulle pour
molière fantasmes ce que bon les jambes
on les affronte à son génial fantasia
comme tout le monde mais je sais pas je
veux pas savoir civile ce à quoi ils le
vivent habituellement je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui va être assez lourd à
porter et je sais pas moi je peux encore
les détails
moi quand ils arrivent ici ils viennent
ils sont bébés leur affaire de grands
elles sont sûres dans un coin de la
pièce
il les voit pas et c'est tout et le
temps qu'ils sont là ils sont bébés le
reste du temps que les femmes qui
viennent des fois non moi j'ai pas de
femmes il y en a mais moi j'en ai pas
mal acquis et il y en a mais il a très
très peu de femmes et un jeune âge je
pense qu'elles sont pas vraiment bébés
sont je pense que c'était peut-être
petite fille pas bien je sais pas bb
c'est pourquoi
voilà je crois je pense que cette 9e
peut-être plus le fils par rapport à la
merde merde que tout le monde ça va
merci 6 et 11 ans d'ailleurs chez une
nounou en fin de compte
ben non pas que ça devait être
prédestiné finalement les blues
plusieurs même pour ses petits bah si tu
t'attaques c'est une grenouillère
problème s'est noyé avec vous mais moi
si tu veux tu as ta taille mais très
courtage même des couches il peut même
quand on m'a dit je ne mets pas mon
problème
c'est un boulot bien que c'est pas
tellement évident parce que bon encore
lui c'est un petit modèle mais bon quand
on tombe sur quelqu'un qui est un peu
grand un peu balèze soir mais 95 120 kg
eux j'en ai trop pour le changer c'est
pas facile
oui ça va c'est un petit modèle enfin en
général ils ont ils sont enfin là dessus
que j'ai rencontré d'un côté tu perds ça
se voit mais presque ouais à la mi temps
où ils ont ils sont tous trop ils ont un
petit côté vraiment versant reste un
côté enfant à côté bébé à côté bon ben
c'est un peu je peux pour accomplir
c'est marrant parce que moi je prends le
train et je regarde les gens maintenant
dans le trash maintien peut-être oui
mais voilà tu vas dire tu deviens
suicide
bien qu'il est bébé tu es bien qu'il est
très bon je pense qu'on a tous eu à
lescar est tellement qu'ils doivent
avoir envie de le faire et au sport et
bien sûr qu'en plus ils croient qu'ils
sont tous seuls voyageurs tenu du délai
tous les coups de téléphone en dix ans
mais je crois que je suis tout seul
comme ça bon c'est vrai que dechavanne a
fait un petit peu que ça bouge que ça
qu'on en parle mais c'est vrai ils ont
tendance à dire bon ben moi je suis un
bon point tout seul un peu isolé et peu
perdu mais c'est vrai qu'il ya plus côté
de ça bon c'est vrai que c'est gentil
c'est pas comme angers dire c'est pas ça
n'a rien de dégradant ça n'a rien de
très palpitant à vivre encore un angle
extérieur comme ça on comprend pas trop
le plaisir que payeur les normes
mais bon j'ai des gens qui ont des idées
est de plus bien que ça et qui est
limite on trouve ça logique entre sa
plus normal
il après tu vas avoir couché ouais après
je ne couche encore un livre blanc et
puis après il dort une anc depuis un
premier bon bah oui
[Musique]
ces vins eaux
pourquoi
bébé pleure pas mais l'effort qui
chouine ouais mais là la première fois
que je les gardais la nuit moi je n'y
croyais pas trop sincère de bd samedi ça
mais c'est un peu ces petits et la
première mi temps qu'il a resté chez moi
je laisse courir d'année il faut il a
chuté comme un bébé
tiens besoin vraiment vraiment un bébé à
côté de moi et c'est vrai que si la nuit
est bon il fouine un petit peu il bouge
un peu ça fait huit bébés réel
et puis bon c'est chez bbc il a pris
position bbc tout le temps très
naturelle on sent bien que c'est pas en
plus souhaite tout ce que j'ai eu moi
qui sont restés à dormir
moi j'ai fait que j'ai le bonheur
puisque bon je dormais cas de biberons
saint guirons dans la nuit dans le
bonheur donc j'aime et à au lycée 9h
9h30 une espèce de déclinant leur tête
parce qu'une fois qu'il ya le biberon
d'eau
ils sont au lit ils dorment même si
c'est quelqu'un qui me dit moi je me
couche tard tu as fait ta rigueur je
suis con veut biberon le lit plein de
s'assommer que le talent c'est bon ou
huit bébés en fait pour ça bouge ça
mange ça dort on fait les cas là je fais
dans une couche n'a même pas pu
s'appeler perdu tous ses biens aux
attentes bon côté
parce qu'en général les mamans elles
veulent toujours qu'ils ont dit très
vite un vrai hein je pense moi je suis
comme ça je pense que j'en avais bu
directives en ce prix est assorti parce
que ça va bien tout petit on va le
laisser dormir
j'aimais dans son biberon d'auto 200 à
talons bis allée
c'est tout
et et de linda hardy tube abonnez vous
je m'étais un peu ce bleu